understaffing really continues to be a
primary concern for many valley
businesses while some say they are
feeling hopeless everyone can agree it's
really becoming a serious problem eight
news now reporter sally jeremiel live in
henderson near saint rose in coronado
with reaction there from businesses
well brian the year is almost coming to
an end and businesses like mothership
coffee roaster says they have tried
everything and still can't get people to
work
a very challenging year not only due to
the pandemic but also with getting
people to work juani romero is the ceo
of mothership coffee roasters she says
they put ads on indeed spending
thousands of dollars trying to find more
employees but no one shows up for
interviews before the pandemic they had
over 62 employees right now hovering at
52 and really need 10 positions filled
without these positions filled it's
taking them a lot longer to push out
drinks and don't have enough people to
make pastries once they run out so we
are not paying for any type of
advertising right now because i am
concerned that the advertising that we
put out there will increase the amount
of traffic we have and
at this point we're at our maximum
capacity to serve our customers as best
as we can amongst their incentives are
offering a robust health insurance that
pays for staff members partners
dependence and mentorship
now out here live romero adds she is
feeling really overwhelmed but is
staying hopeful and really wants to
remind everyone to please be patient to
her employees sally caramillo live local
now